so good afternoon I am Betsy Humphries
deputy director of the National Library
of Medicine and on behalf of the
fabulous multi-disciplinary staff of the
National Library of Medicine and the
friends of the National Library of
Medicine I'm welcome to all of you we
are really both those of you who are in
the room and we think we have a lot of
people watching us the video cast across
the country maybe around the world as
well
so we are delighted however that so many
distinguished guests have traveled here
to be with us some over long distances
and I would like to extend our special
welcome to Lois Flatley and a number of
Patty's sisters brothers and other
relatives who are able to come with us
we're particularly delighted to have
them here
uh I think that nlm is very rich in its
advisors partners and supporters and I'm
going to acknowledge just a few of them
who are here with us today I can't
possibly acknowledge all of you but
first Bob greenus who is chair of the
nlm Board of Regents we have a number of
other regions uh both present and former
with us today which is great we have
Barbara Redmond president and Glenn
Campbell chair of the board of the
friends of nlm and a number of other
friends friends in in the room
we have uh
Teresa not president and Kevin baliozian
executive director of the medical
Library Association and a number of
other leaders and partners and
supporters including International
network of libraries of medicine here
today so thank you all for being here
and I believe we have Doug fritzma who
is the president and CEO of the American
medical informatics Association
nlm has not only many partners around
the world and out in the field but we
have a lot of great Partners across
federal agencies and of course here
within the NIH and we're very glad that
um uh I think Susanna Fox who is the
chief technology officer of the HHS is
here and I think perhaps also uh we have
John White who is the Deputy National
coordinator of the national uh Deputy
National coordinator of Health
Information Technology and from right
here at NIH Gary Gibbons who is the
director of nhlbi and Pat Grady who is
the director of the National Institute
of nursing research and I have to say
within here we really welcome the very
large number of nursing leaders from
across the country who are with us today
thank you all for being here
so
and we have Francis Collins
the director of NIH
[Music]
so today is definitely a day for looking
to the future but I'm going to take a
few minutes to set the stage by
reviewing some historical Milestones
that have brought nlm to its current
position when the within the world of
biomedical and health information and
data as it happens 2016 is the
180th anniversary of the establishment
of nlm's earliest predecessor Library
within the office of the Surgeon General
of the army
and 2016 is also the 60th
anniversary of the passage of the
National Library of Medicine act which
in 1956
transferred the Armed Forces Medical
Library from the Department of Defense
into what was then the department of
health education and Welfare
and in addition to renaming the library
this act which was co-sponsored by
Senators Lister Hill you're here today
and John F Kennedy gave an alignments
great Mission and I'm going to read this
to you quote
to assist the advancement of the medical
and related scientist sciences and to
Aid the dissemination and exchange of
scientific and other information
important to the progress of medicine
and to the public health end quote let
me hasten to add for this audience that
the ACT explicitly defined medicine in
medical
to include preventive and therapeutic
medicine Dentistry Pharmacy
hospitalization nursing public health
and the fundamental Sciences related
there too and other related fields of
study research or activity
in addition to enumerating the basic nlm
functions that support permanent access
to the world's biomedical literature the
law also requires the library quote to
engage in such other activities as the
secretary determines appropriate
so in the 1960s the scope of nlm was
radically expanded by both the Congress
and the secretary in terms of adding
Grant Authority creating our first
intramural research division the Lister
hill national Center for biomedical
communication specifically in joining us
to create a toxicology Information
Program
transferring the Public Health Service
audio visual facility to the National
Library of Medicine from the CDC and I
could go on the um
the scope of what we do and particularly
the addition of our grant program in
1965 in our in and the requirement to
create the national network of libraries
of medicine just radically expanded what
the library did
and set the stage the programs that came
out of those expansions set the stage
for the next big set of expansions which
began in 1988 with the legislation that
created the national Center for
biotechnology information Within nlm
acts which also expanded our activities
in Health Services Research
General assignments to the government
but also to nlm in terms of clinical
trials registration and to the NIH in
terms of Public Access
I think that I always say that February
2000 was one of the great months in the
history of nlm because it was the month
that both PubMed Central our public
access to article uh our public Archive
of articles in the in biomedicine but
also clinicaltrials.gov debuted that
that same month so I think that we later
were assigned responsibilities by
secretaries in areas related to health
data standards and Health Services
Research
and we have arrived today with a very
wide-ranging set of activities that
affect virtually all aspects of
biomedical information and Health Data
in some way shape or form
and
Patty comes to us now as the 19th person
the first nurse and the first woman to
officially be appointed as the library's
director
the first appointed director was
actually John Shaw Billings before that
there wasn't a director he was appointed
in 1865 and as many of you know
he was then actually purposely
transformed the library of the surgeon
general's office into a national Medical
Library he established the index Medicus
and other cataloging indexing things
that are precursor of PubMed today he
was also
involved in greatly expanding The
Collection so when he left we were the
largest Medical Library in the world as
we still are today and established many
of our Nationwide services
so
Patty if we move forward to the modern
area era is just the fourth person to
serve as the Director of the library
since it has been named the National
Library of Medicine
and I have had the distinct pleasure and
privilege of knowing all of these great
leaders and working for and with three
of them now including Patty
in my view they all represent exactly
the right choice at the right time
in the case of Paddy's three
predecessors each prepared the way for
the next person in essence transforming
the National Library of Medicine
and its directorship into a job that
would appeal to the next person
we are all fortunate that Don
Lindbergh's expansion of nlm's programs
and scientific data electronic health
records public health services to
patients and the public
have made this job attractive to Patty
Brennan
so it is my great pleasure to introduce
Patricia Flatley Brennan to present her
first public remarks as the Director of
the National Library of Medicine Patty
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
wow
I feel very welcomed and I want to thank
you all for giving up this finely
beautiful afternoon in Washington DC to
come inside
I'm am delighted honored and just
absolutely
gratified to be standing here as the
fourth director of the National Library
of Medicine in a line of 19 important
leaders but none has been more important
than Betsy Humphries who took the
responsibility for a 16-month period to
transition to consider continue to
accelerate and to bring the library to a
place that it needs to be and I thank
her so much for her work
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I also want to thank the audio visual
program development branch and the
communications team for this tremendous
afternoon it's going to be a great time
they've worked very hard and they've
spent an awful lot of time preparing
materials to help you understand what I
am now learning about I've been here
three weeks I think it's appropriate to
start a little bit to introduce myself
to you some of you I know many I'm
starting to get to know and some I've
lived with for quite a while
I am a mother of Connor up here I am a
daughter of Lois and Tom I'm a sister to
my siblings and a friend and colleague I
hope and trust to my friends those here
present and those around the world that
I've had the privilege of working with
I for the past 30 years I have Blended
two professions nursing and industrial
engineering in the service of people
living at home learning to take care of
themselves coping with complex problems
nursing brings to this challenge a
fundamental unique focus on the person
on the diagnosis and treatment of human
response to disease development or
disability we are concerned about the
response to fundamental pathologies and
Trauma we bring something no one else
brings industrial Engineers bring a
focus on technological solutions to
complex problems so what a great mix
this was now my focus has been primarily
on reaching into the home which is not a
place you usually see industrial
engineers and the challenge of reaching
into the home brings us into a place
that's intimate private unstructured and
the place where most health occurs
we spent a lot of our time visiting
homes we've been in over a thousand
homes in Wisconsin alone and we learned
many things from that but fundamentally
we learned that people don't like
engineers and nurses tracing through
their bedrooms so we had to find a
better way to bring our understanding on
our solutions to those in need we
developed through the techniques of
virtual reality and 3D rendering the
opportunity to recreate households is
point clouds and then study them in
depth in virtual reality caves and then
begun to learn things such as health
occurs all over the house that little
pill box that you carry with you
actually has to fit in your pocket it
doesn't do any good if it just sits on
the counter and in fact sometimes Health
occurs in the middle of the night when
people feel the most private so as we
build tools and Technology to deliver
information into people's hands as they
need it we have to think about where
they are
but thinking about where they are and
thinking about the home leads me to tell
you a little bit more about my family
for a few minutes
it's quite a family story maybe a myth
that the Seventh Son of the Seventh Son
will be king of Ireland
now our dear Dad was the Seventh Son in
a large Irish Catholic Family and he met
not a lovely mother and they looked
forward to starting on the dynasty
and they began and first there was Gene
you'll meet these people this afternoon
most of them are here first there was
Gene and then there was me and then
Kathleen this was not looking very good
but then our brother Kevin came along
and our brother Tim and hope had
returned to the family and then all of a
sudden Eileen
but then Brian and then Sean and then
Tom things are looking better but then
Bridget and then that's what we had so
there were 10 of us and there was no
king of Ireland so I'm here to say
what exactly is there for the second
daughter of the Seventh Son
and it is the opportunity at this point
in my career at this point in our lives
at this point in society to work with
this amazing group of 1700 professionals
and colleagues and employers and
Librarians and patients around the world
to bring information to the point of
health and information to the point of
need so in my remarks today I'm going to
do three things we'll be drawing from
our history we'll be doing a lot of
celebrating of our present and I'm going
to ask you to work with me some to
anticipate our future
Betsy remarked of the importance of John
Shaw Billings to us who brought the idea
that information came from the past and
yet comes into the present to be have
the library be a dynamic interplay of
medicine and information so that in the
year 2000 Don limber could create a
network around the world that anywhere
where people were there was electronic
access to the information needed for
medicine some of those who helped shape
this program are in this room right now
and I'm grateful for what you did one of
those is leaving next week to go back to
Africa We are continuing to focus the
resources of the National Library of
Medicine around the world recognizing
that we draw from our past and it
becomes a vibrant present for us
the goal is to make sure information is
available everywhere and assure that
that information is Meaningful and
useful at the point of need
so let's take a look at some of the
things we've been doing
the National Library of Medicine is
first and foremost has as its Vision to
support discovery
our vision is to deport support
discovery and we do this in two primary
ways the first way is to examine explore
and cultivate and expand the basic
biomedical information sciences and
Library Sciences to make sure that the
tools needed for you to be able to take
care of yourself bring information that
is actionable Meaningful understandable
useful to everyone but we also provide
the knowledge platform for biomedical
science discoveries we accelerate the
ability of its talented and smart
investigators to understand their
phenomenon to communicate it to others
and to learn and to realize in faster
and faster ways right now we run I
research and training program in our
extreme real area and I'd like to focus
on two candidates from each of those
areas to tell you about what we actually
do
Emily Mallory is a graduate student a
PhD student at Stanford University her
work is to study large-scale extraction
of Gene interactions from the full text
literature using Deep dive a natural
language processing tool there's lots
and lots of information out there it's
growing too quickly for human Minds to
read so Emily's work is going to help us
extract from the literature these
interactions and categorize them and
make them accessible for other workers
Justin Maurer who is at Rice University
is trying to improve drug safety by
using data mining techniques to mine the
vast literature we have at nlm to First
discover interactions no one can read
all of the Articles we have here
maori's work is trying to help us glean
from information from there using some
of our text processing and
representation tools to be able to make
this information accessible to machine
learning algorithm so he's not simply
going through and cultivating did
researcher a find find result B but he's
going through and trying to map how
often certain patterns emerged what were
precursors and how we can better
understand them these are our young
people our pre-doc and postdoc trainees
and we're very proud of them we have 14
programs around the country to train
predocs and postdocs
in addition we have we run a range of
extramural programs both research and
extension I'm going to point out two of
our researchers Scott Maurer who is a
new investigator has an award where he
is at Arizona State University by the
way in Tempe he's looking to merge viral
genetics and climate and population data
to be able to understand human animal or
zoonotic zoonotic disease and genetic
surveillance so he's trying to bring
together ideas about how the climate
around you the experience that you have
and the population that you're living
with can make or influence your ability
to be susceptible to diseases
in addition Elizabeth Chen at Brown
University she's right looking through
the electronic health record trying to
better understand family linkages as we
learn about hereditable diseases and
also as we learn about the adult health
effects of childhood exposures
understanding a person not as a point in
time but as a life flow is essential and
our investigators are building the tools
that allow us to do this and again I'm
extremely proud of them
we also though in addition to building
tools we reach in an archive and cult
present history to the world our history
of medicine division recently presented
a program a an installation called
confronting violence what's important
about this program isn't only that we
understood aspects that contributed to
the understanding of violence but how
health professionals developed policies
and procedures that enabled them to
manage to understand to detect violence
in a person they needed to bring
together what we would call the gray
literature meeting notes from hospital
meetings small guidelines from
institutions as they began to understand
and confront this problem which we now
know broadly is violence and intimate
partner violence without aspects without
Explorations like that we would not
first of all be able to call the
Public's attention in a meaningful way
to how knowledge builds but more
importantly we would not be able to
document how knowledge builds this is
critical for us
the National Library of Medicine
accelerates and plays a critical role in
shaping the federal policy on open
science
we developed the first model Open Access
strategy that has now been adopted by
many federal agencies in which the
research findings built on federal funds
your tax dollars are made available
quickly and broadly and without
restriction to the General Public
we have also worked to make sure that
their vast resources of the National
Library of Medicine are available
through open apis open application
programming interfaces so that others
who want to build tools Upon Our work
are able to do that so we export not
only
access to the knowledge but tools to
help use the knowledge this is a great
thing recently we've begun to take up
the Federal challenge the federal excuse
me the federal government's America
creates charge to create challenges the
National Library of Medicine image
recognition challenge was a way to
engage citizens in science public data
available for scientists and lay people
to improve patient safety and the basic
question that was asked was can your
cell phone tell what pill that is this
could be useful can a cell phone tell
what pill it is can help an individual
family member in the middle of the night
trying to understand what was that pill
that my kid swallowed what's going on
with me what do I need to do and our
first prize winner came from a team of
students at Michigan State University
they were able given a training set of 7
000 images and one thousand testing
images to identify 75 percent of the
pills accurately what we're learning is
how to take emerging Technologies cell
phones simple smartphone Technologies
and use that to help people better their
own health at a point where they need to
be and where we need to support them
we are also trying to improve health
care we ultimately do not give care but
our standards of terminologies are human
factors understanding of teams our
delivery of disaster information in the
moment all allow us to ensure that the
information needed by health
professionals at the point of care is
available there and secondarily that
that information flows into a larger and
more complete understanding of all of
the kinds of practice-based
interventions that lead to an
improvement in the health of our
populations watch with me for a moment
while we celebrate our present in the
work going on here at the National
Library of Medicine
[Music]
thank you
this is a great place to work
the accomplishments of the colleagues
and the directors and the managers and
the staff that have gone before me
provide a basis for us to know that we
can
develop the resources needed to help
meet the challenges of the world
I want you to anticipate with me for a
few minutes what the future may hold for
the health of the population for the
health of your family for yourself it's
important for us at the National Library
of Medicine to think about what
challenges lie ahead in healthcare
because we need to be ready with the
information resources and supports
needed to either help discover and
characterize them or to sufficiently
bring information to be able to assist
with them now you all each have your own
three or four top health care concerns
of the moment and if you don't I ask you
to take a minute right now to think of
them because they are what drives us to
create the information tools to be
responsive
I'd like to call three to your attention
first the genetic discoveries of the
last 20 years have heralded a promise of
precision medicine that now may be
realized so we may know not to give you
coding because you lack the gene that
converts the enzyme that makes the
coding
pharmacologically accessible to you or
it may be better to treat you with a
certain approach to your cancer than
what was originally thought based on
your symptom mythology
but it also requires us that we help
every person understand this complex
twisty genome inside of them and ways to
do that and that reach across the
literacy lines that reach into the
everyday schools of children that reach
to my mom are part of our purview
second infectious disease remains hugely
problematic and what we're learning more
because of our work here at the National
Library of Medicine is that mutations
occur quickly and differentially across
the world understanding how those
mutations are occurring when to
anticipate where they might be emerging
will allow clinicians to better respond
to them and finally we must mention
chronic diseases asthma diabetes
hypertension there they continue
unabated and they're in some ways
growing and while I have been a part of
the community that has said let the
patients participate for they will help
us I also recognize the good intentions
is not enough powerful information
effective information tools good
surveillance are also necessary so
infectious diseases excuse me so chronic
disease management which will be remain
a partnership between professionals and
patients has a third leg of that stool
that I think of as the National Library
of Medicine
as we think towards how we will help
what will we do
the National Library of Medicine has
certain things we can do in certain
things we can't do I'm going to bring
forward three challenges that I hope
will be able to do we don't do surgery
upstairs and we have no blood banks here
but we can begin to take a life span and
a life flow approach to understanding
complex chronic diseases to understand
the consequences in adult health of
childhood exposures and begin to think
of Health not as a moment in time but as
a process across time that requires us
to rethink how we index that requires us
to understand sequential inversioning
activities that requires us to
understand information as an interaction
not as a delivery mechanism
second we need to we can support the
creation of a learning health system
that better leverage data to better
foster effective health care we can do
this by improving the dissemination and
use of standard ways of expressing
Health Care problems of assuring that
your headache in New York is described
in the same way as your headache in
California but more importantly is the
computational models that underlie that
are available and accessible and can be
applied to information
and finally I believe most that we can
continue as a library to do what we've
done we've started over the years which
is enabling improved treatment and
better self-management by harnessing
Technologies
we are not the national heart lung and
Blood Institute we're not going to
understand and discover the basic
physiology but we will be able to
provide tools for understanding for
accelerating that understanding and for
people to take action on them so now
walk with me as we anticipate our future
a little bit
what should the National Library of
Medicine do well one of the things I've
learned in the first three weeks that
I've been here is that the director
doesn't have a whole lot of say over
this but the director can shine a
spotlight and and and provide a little
Direction and sometimes nudge with a
little money and that's where I will be
spending my next few years
but remember first and foremost the
National Library of Medicine is about
Discovery and Discovery in two planes
one is supporting the biomedical
Sciences discoveries and secondarily to
understanding basic biomedical
informatics discoveries we need better
natural language processing tools we
need the ability to have privacy
preserving algorithms to run our data on
we have the possibility to assist in the
development of information making it
accessible to the millions and millions
of people that reach us every week and
the millions and millions more computers
that seem to be talking to our computers
without any human intermediary
our investigators who specialize in
imaged analysis and exploration in a
natural language processing are building
new tools that we can now search on a
squiggle we can investigate and look for
shapes rather than looking for words
this brings us great promise
it would be inappropriate and
unresponsible to not address the
importance of standards as we go into
the next period of our work here
standards are of a way of making sure
that information flows freely without
information flowing freely words can
flow freely but they can't be processed
or understood so to make knowledge flow
freely we need structured ways to
represent it bibliographic standards
tell us how to represent Library
catalogs information standards tell us
how to represent how to understand the
experience of a person nowhere and never
before has it been more important to
have attention and systematic approaches
to standards and my colleagues who are
in the audience are listening Country
Boy probably never expected to hear me
say that but standards are essential to
the future why because the amount of
information that's coming at us is
Flowing way too fast and standards are
one way to organize it not the only but
one way and we must continue to invest
in these now allowing the genomic
scientists to use an electronic health
record to understand the phenotype is
only going to happen if those records
are accessible in a way that the genomic
science on scientist understands them so
standards are us
now partnering is really critical for
the National Library of medicine's
future we are just like BSF BASF rather
we don't make the information we make it
accessible useful safe stored available
and curated our responsibilities to make
sure that what scientists need or
clinicians want or patients look for can
be gotten without a lot of barriers
without a lot of cost and with with a
great deal of trust the imprimatur of
trust of Our National Library of
Medicine allows our partnering
scientists to be sure that what we
deliver them is accurate is create is
correct and current we must remember
that this is a job that only the
National Library of Medicine can do and
we do it really well we have to continue
to do this
the future is a future of data the data
will come from
all sorts of places right now
we're most familiar with cellular
molecular data genomic data and symptoms
but there's new data elements out there
even now that tell us about the health
of people that give us a chance to
ensure that we can get into their hands
and to understand from their experience
what's going on sound of a baby crying
or a family having an argument the
motion of a person walking after surgery
these are all data types that we've only
just begun to explore and our work in
image Technologies has got to expand to
help us understand the fluid motion and
the ability to understand from tonal
sounds something about the person but in
addition we meet we have a challenge to
think about data Beyond an individual
person at this point in time we've
gotten pretty good about identifying a
person at least in one record we still
can't link them very well yet but that's
coming but now we need to think about
what is the data element of a
partnership of a family of a community
or of a population it's more than just
the aggregation of the individual visual
population genomics calls us to
understand a lot more about how and
health and illness flow through a
community and our data structures and
the way we curate them and make them
available are going to require us to
think in a whole new fashion the nih's
investment in data science will be
accelerated by the knowledge embedded in
the National Library of Medicine
we must improve dissemination we've
actually done pretty well you can go to
any kiosk cell phone or a computer in
the world and come to see some of our
resources this is pretty good but
dissemination in a way that is
Meaningful that doesn't require the
human to sift through volumes of
information this is something that our
specialized Information Services has
skill a skill set in our library
operations people are thinking about
constantly not just opening the door and
let anyone see what we have but open the
door provide a filter Let It Be
accessible let it be understood in a
timely and relevant fashion we have a
lot of work to do so let's see another
video so we can anticipate the future
together
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
we're here today to anticipate the third
Century we've got about 20 years to get
there it's not a long time
we need your help we need the guidance
and we need the work of the fact the
sorry The Faculty the staff the uh our
board of directors our community our
Board of Regents the community members
that work with us to help us chart a
future tomorrow morning I'm going to be
charging the Board of Regents to perform
a committee that will guide the
strategic planning process for the
National Library of Medicine we'd like
to have a vision that could see 10 years
in the future and help us understand
what to do in the next five years
one year it will take us at least to do
this one whole year with the support of
Dr Collins and the leadership at NIH we
have the one year to make this vision
and figure out how to make it real we
have challenges to resources we have
challenges to Sacred traditions and we
have challenges to the uncertainty of
newness but we can face these we the
1700 workers of the National Library of
Medicine already are thinking into the
future and we want you to begin to think
there with us we will be engaging with
stakeholder communities with our
associations that support our work and
with the people professionals and lay
who are at the receiving end of our
information we will be conducting a
functional audit of what do we really do
as I walk through these amazing
buildings and we are actually housed in
five different buildings I find every
day something new that we are doing
something important something
interesting and often expressed with
great pride by the person who does this
and the person who's doing this our
functional audit of our current
investments will be complemented by
listening sessions to the challenges the
nlm's response to those challenges and
those listening sessions will involve
the NIH as a community will involve
involve the biomedical informatics and
Library science communities our primary
stakeholders and the population at large
it's a lot of people to reach and we're
going to look for a lot of support with
this and finally we're going to be
evaluating our physical plant because
yes our computers are great and our
books are beautiful and there's many
Treasures but sometimes our stairways
are dark and sometimes our rooms leak
and we need to attend to that so we will
be complementing a visioning of the
future a functional audit of our current
activities with an understanding of what
is needed to make sure that the National
Library of Medicine Remains the jewel in
the crown of the NIH I thank thank you
for this opportunity and I trust you'll
keep in touch and work along with me and
my colleagues as we make this happen
thank you
[Applause]
I'm sure that you all can understand why
I was terribly enthused when I heard
that Patty would be our next director
and I've become more enthused with every
each passing day that she's been here
for the last three weeks so it's been
great now it is my pleasure to introduce
the director of the National Institutes
of Health Francis Collins he has many
achievements and he's done many great
things and as I think you can all tell
one of the greatest things he's done
recently is appoint Patty Brennan as
director of NLF thank you
[Applause]
well I agree with that
Patty wonderful remarks inspirational
walking us through where we've been
where we are now and especially where we
are going and I think we all share the
excitement that you have conveyed and
we're on your team and want to make this
dream turn into something really
spectacular and you're just the right
leader to make that happen
I also really want to say thank you to
Betsy Humphries for her wonderful
leadership over these 16 months keeping
the nlm on a very remarkable course and
all the things you've done for nlm
before that as you outlined all of the
many other folks you've worked with here
and the leadership you have shown you
have been a wonderful dedicated public
servant and you have made this place
really wonderful so thank you for that
Betsy
I often say that nlm is nih's window to
the world this is an absolutely critical
part of everything we do
most of those people out there in this
country and in other countries who know
something about NIH and seek information
from NIH they come in through this
portal
and this portal has been remarkably well
designed to serve those needs and yet
the challenges are growing almost by the
hour maybe we shouldn't be in here
spending time we should be out there
figuring out how to make nlm better but
we'll get there and you have the right
leader to make that happen so we can
stop for a little bit and celebrate
what's been accomplished and think hard
about where this needs to go next with
this new leader
this is a great day I think for NIH to
have the opportunity here that I will in
a moment of swearing in Dr Patty Brennan
as the next director
you can hear from her vision that she's
already on the path to thinking about
doing great things here
no one knows better than I the challenge
of trying to find leaders to come and be
part of our senior Visionary group at
NIH
and no one knows better than I what a
challenge it is for an organization like
nlm to find the right person with the
right skill set given the broad
diversity of what this institution has
on its list of responsibilities
so the task was daunting
how could we find in a single person
the many talents and abilities needed to
lay the groundwork for what you've just
heard about nlm's third century
but when we found Patty Brennan I'm
proud to say we found the entire package
she brings with her this incredible set
of experiences
that includes having cared for patients
as a practicing nurse
but she's got the tech side covered here
extremely well too that Industrial
Engineer attitude but brought to a very
interesting place as you have heard
improving the lives of homebound
patients by developing Innovative
information systems and services and
picking the opportunity to utilize
Cutting Edge efforts in visualization
and virtual reality to add to that body
of data
so putting all those skills together I
believe makes her ideally suited to lead
the nlm in the era of precision medicine
where we are increasingly trying to
figure out how can science get together
with this desire to empower individuals
to be able to experience a better health
span as well as a better lifespan
and the library is going to become more
than ever the epicenter for biomedical
data science which is going to be the
foundation of everything we try to do in
Precision medicine
and so there could hardly be a more
important moment to have the right
leader and you can tell from you've what
you've heard this afternoon that we were
very fortunate indeed to recruit Patty
Brennan if that weren't enough in terms
of the skill sets and the resumes
I'm also able to testify that Patty is a
wonderful human being
you've just had a great example of her
communication skills
she's also a lively presence on Twitter
and is about to launch a Blog to talk
about nlm
but I have found in the brief time that
I've been able to share ideas and talk
about sometimes challenging problems
with Patty that her ability to sift
through those issues and to come across
with a view that is both nuanced and
optimistic is exactly what we need and
so many of these rooms where we're
wrestling with these issues
so I think now that my Twitter feed is
coming out rather nicely now with my
sixty four thousand followers I might
have a run for my money here somebody
who really knows how to communicate
we'll see how that all goes
so again without further Ado because I
know there's a reception and probably
all of you would like to have a chance
to extend your congratulations and we
also want to hear in a moment from the
chair of the Board of Regents but we
have a special moment now which is the
swearing-in
the the oath of office which I'm about
to ask Dr Brennan to read is a
historical document it is the same oath
of office that is spoken by every member
of Congress when they come after just
being elected or re-elected
it's the same oath of office that is
recited by the Vice President by the
members of the cabinet by judges
although judges have another oath they
have to do as well they have double oath
requirements
and all of us who have been at NIH have
read this same oath some of us twice for
different positions so you're connected
in this way through a long tradition by
the way the president's oath is a little
different
maybe that explains why the Supreme
Court Justice stumbled over it a couple
years ago we won't go back to that
but the oath that Patty's being asked to
read has been the one that has held us
all together and it's a solemn moment
a moment that someone like Dr Brennan
with all of her skills and all of her
talents and all of her contributions
stating her desire to be a public
servant to the people of the United
States and to defend the Constitution it
is I think something we will all kind of
Be Touched by and remember
and we're particularly fortunate here
that Dr Brennan's sister Gene Flatley
McGuire is going to join us up here and
hold a copy of the Constitution which if
you read the program is a special one as
the oath is administered so Patty can I
ask you to come up and Gene Flatley
McGuire also and having done this a few
times I recognize that there's
no I think I'm there and I think you're
there well I might have to rearrange
this
I want you in the middle there you go
there you go and I'll be here all right
we have the right
my brother clearly we did not rehearse
this
okay and there is this wonderful
Constitution and um what I'm going to do
is ask you to repeat after me and I will
go through relatively few words at a
time because otherwise it's easy for
both of us to get mixed up so may I ask
you to put your left hand on the
Constitution and to raise your right
hand and repeat after me
I state your name I Patricia Flatley
Brennan do solemnly swear do solemnly
swear that I will support and defend
that I will support and defend the
Constitution of the United States the
Constitution of the United States
against all enemies against all enemies
foreign and domestic foreign and
domestic that I will bear true faith
that I will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same and allegiance to
the same that I take this obligation
freely that I take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion or purpose of evasion
and that I will well and faithfully and
that I will well and Faithfully
discharge the duties of the office
discharge the duties of the office on
which I'm about to enter on which I am
about to enter so help me God so help me
God congratulations thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and now I'll introduce the chairman of
the Board of Regents of the National
Library of Medicine Dr Robert greenis
and he will have the last few words
well this is a very tough act to follow
and uh I'm standing between you in uh
Refreshments so I'll be very brief but I
am representing the Board of Regents
and the on behalf of the board I want to
extend our enthusiastic welcome to Patty
as the Director of the National Library
of Medicine
this really couldn't happen at a more
important time I think we've talked
about the learning health system and
we're facing a number of challenges
political Financial social and
technological and trying to make that
happen
and the library is uniquely positioned
to capitalize on marshaling the science
that's coming out of NIH and elsewhere
sharing the knowledge and making it
available and interoperable uh in order
to pull together this very complex
multifaceted health system and Health
Care system that we have in this country
and in the world
so recognizing the importance of playing
a leading role in shepherding this
complex process
the net the Board of Regents is working
with Patty as Patty mentioned
to launch a new strategic planning
initiative
and to engage the broad community of
stakeholders in this process
so we're very excited and I'm personally
excited to be chair at this point in
time of the board as this process
unfolds and with a new leader like Patty
to help us to think through this and to
implement our vision
I I wanted to just add a couple personal
notes I think I've known Patty
for some 28 years I actually looked up I
think we were both invited to give a
talk at Salt Lake City 28 years ago and
that's when I got to know her first
and since then we've had the privilege
of getting to know each other through
multiple committees uh joint uh working
sessions of various things we've had
brainstorming sessions in some of our
national meetings
and we've also shared some postdoc and
student uh and fact Junior faculty
mentees that we've co uh mentored
and what I've learned over this time and
continue to be impressed by is Patty's
insights her broad perspective
her organizational skills and ability to
cut to the Chase and I think we've seen
all this and also her leadership
so the nlm I am confident is in
excellent hands as we embark on this
exciting future
again our congratulations and warmest
welcome to Patty
and then I would like to just close with
uh letting you know that the reception
awaits where you will have a chance to
talk with Patty and wish her well
and also to inquire about the next steps
and I want to mention that the reception
food and refreshments are provided by
the friends of the National Library of
Medicine so thank you
[Applause]
I was like yeah
thank you